I walk into the house and stick my hand
out to come the first man I think you
look gotten over that we're all upstairs
and I was chatting when I suddenly
noticed there was no commander move
Charles upstairs
so this disturbs me so I make my way to
go downstairs Finn I know what I'm going
to confront myself trying to stop you
from getting downstairs don't I don't go
down there I'm just gonna pry my husband
I go downstairs
it's a very happy - threesome going on
downstairs I'm gonna childhood a man who
I don't know anyone it's not like this
is your moment
so it's happened I'm joining the
competition just oh my best friend and I
said come on I'd like to have a word you
mean [ __ ] really uncomfortable for the
head - oh yes I said to me okay boys we
shall move communi and I'll be out for a
minute and they shot upstairs like
chickens in their heads and I could feel
upstairs or how breaking with what she
going to do so I said come on let's
dance mishap time hmm I wasn't terrified
them and I said come and I just like to
renew it's actually what's going on
which is I don't know what you're
talking about that's what I know what
feeling chain which means move and she
said to avenge today she said to me
you've got everything you've ever wanted
oh she beautiful evening you want I
don't even know what she said anyway so
I said I want one husband I'm just a
brat and she looked down hold on
I said to her I'm sorry I'm in the way I
don't see her anyway I don't need to be
half
[Music]
in the column a that my husband was
ailing like a bad rash I cried
I'm gonna cry before it was anger it was
seven years of pent-up anger yeah
cry and asleep that night and you're
next when we work out and I thought
different [ __ ] to mentorship I done
something said what I felt still real
jealousy nervous willing around but it
wasn't so death as it's been before and
I said to him but the we came through
this age I said Oh Diane Sawyer watch
there what I thought you coming up
there's no secret to me ask her I just
said I loved you with nothing wrong in
that
[Music]